he told you senator rand paul calling
out the media after newly released
emails show
a key wuhan researcher thanked dr fauci
for downplaying the coronavirus lab
league theory but still
the press wasted no time gushing over
the emails 3 000
plus actually praising their frank
honesty
and the pressure that one that fell on
one man's shoulders
senator rand paul joins us now to react
senator i watch you with laura last
night i've been watching along the way
we also watched your
exchange with dr fauci live what do the
3
200 emails tell you well they tell me
that early on he was very worried you
know there's a disturbing picture
he gets an email or he gets notification
of what's going on in wuhan
and he immediately sends something to
his assistant an email saying
we must meet immediately read this
article
and in the subject line in the article
it says gain of function research
in wuhan well he still denies to this
day that he was funding it
and as you know gain of function is
where you take an animal virus
and you make it into a super virus that
infects humans
they were doing this at the wuhan lab dr
fauci still denies it to this day
but in his private emails he puts in the
subject line
urgent we must discuss this gain of
function research
so he knows it's gain of function and he
needs to be pinned down on this
there are scientists across america who
will dispute what he's saying
who says that specifically the grant and
the money given to wuhan
that dr fauci approved that it was gain
of function research and we need to talk
to these scientists
in this field and hear from them about
how dr falchi is not being honest with
the american people you know just the
tone of some of these emails even though
some of them are redacted some of them
redacted
show the urgency basically omg uh
i can are we basically responsible for
that and should the guy who's funding
these labs be in charge of telling
america how to handle it
and what happened here there's a there's
a disconnect to
putting him in charge that was a big
mistake yeah so early on you know i was
somewhat perceived
all these scientists were telling me
that it couldn't have come from the lab
and i listened to them but then i
discovered that they had not revealed
that they were the very scientists that
were funding the lab so the conflict of
interest is this
if this virus came from the lab there's
a certain amount of at least
moral culpability to the people who are
advocating for this
dr fauci to this day says he still
trusts the chinese scientists
i don't think he seems to be aware of
the way it works in a communist
government
do you think there aren't military
generals in that lab as well
do you think some of the scientists
aren't also in the communist party and
the military
so i don't think that having trust of
chinese scientists
with gain and function research was very
wise in fact it was so naive
that we shouldn't have dr fauci in a
position of advising the u.s
the world or anybody else because he's
so shown such poor decision-making so i
watched you brawl with him many times
but i thought
in a fair way and he would try to answer
your questions but the question was was
he telling the truth
one of which is unmasked you told him
i've had it already
i have the antibodies we don't know that
for sure if you need to wear a mask we
have an
email of him saying cloth masks don't
work to somebody else
so he tells one side one scientist is
trying to urge him to tell the country
to wear masks
he's telling somebody else they don't
work what do you think
he thinks it's the very definition of
theater
if you ask him about immunity if you ask
him privately if i've had the disease do
i and all likelihood have immunity
he'll say yes but then he'll say oh
we're going to completely discount it
and this is a very important public
policy decision in india
there's a billion people 400 000 people
a day are getting this they have 4 000
people a day dying at least
and so there's a real question should
you give the vaccine to people who've
already had the disease
or should you save the vaccine for
people who haven't been infected
there's not enough vaccine to go around
in india this isn't probably the most
important public
policy or public health decision in the
world right now but because dr
fauci isn't being honest about immunity
they may well be giving the vaccine to
people already infected
which is not allowing enough people to
get vaccinated for them to get to herd
immunity and dr rand paul
this is something people should keep in
mind if he has the checkbook
and he's funding these labs and these
are research that the researchers want
funded why would they ever come out
against him
they would be against their own
interests so this
this formula doesn't work for america
well he has yet to apologize or even
admit that they were doing gain of
function research
even though his private emails admit
immediately to his underling oh my
goodness
we have to do something immediately
about this gain of function research
so he admits in private what he won't
say in public and this is a big deal
because
if you would at least say made a mistake
there might be some consideration
but he's still denying that we funded
the wu on lab gain and function research
or that they were doing it
or that it was an unwise decision
there's a bigger decision also brian we
have 11 labs in the united states
doing gain of function now i don't give
our researchers bad motives i think our
researchers are good people
but i worry about the idea of whether we
should take the spanish flu
and try to transmit it and make it
easier to infect it with humans
but that's a good idea whether it could
possibly escape in the u.s
as well so this research many many
scientists not just people in the
political world
but many scientists are very very wary
of this and i'm going to try to have a
hearing in washington i don't think the
democrats will allow us to do it
officially
but i'm going to try to have a open
discussion in the capital
bringing in the scientists who discuss
and are worried about getting a function
most of these people are not partisans
they're not republicans or democrats
they're just scientists
but they're impartial scientists who
have been worried about this for a
decade
that this could happen yeah actually
what you brought up is not partisan
either
i think we're all against uh the
coronavirus
and stopping the next one uh and you've
been there first
uh hashtag fire factory i know exactly
how you feel going into the segment
and i don't think you've changed your
mind during senator rand paul
thanks for bringing all this from front
and center appreciate it